hey guys so it's basically our first day
at Sundance today yesterday we traveled
and so now we're here we're about to do
some interview with billboard they're
doing this awesome whoo nerd fest
concert series here so there's gonna be
tons of awesome bands first up I'm doing
interview Kevin Bacon sometimes excited
and Jen and I love the following we do
hey guys it's Justine and we are here at
Sundance 2015 with a billboard
Winterfest and we're hanging out with
Kevin Bacon and you're promoting a new
film cop car kept going
tell me everything that I need to know
about it I call it kind of like a
thriller I'd say what's a thriller it's
about two young kids they're about 11
mm-hmm I see a cop car and they steal to
say that they stole the wrong cop car
would be an understatement yeah so we
just finished up doing some rehearsals
and I did my Kevin Bacon interview and
it was awesome he was so fancy you'll be
going to his in the street singing we'll
be going to the egg you later today and
potentially might interview her so we'll
see how this goes is gonna fun day so
far so you're about to perform and here
at Sundance I am so excited about this I
would be more excited if I got to go in
a tubing coming here I saw a live in a
tubing going on and I am very mad I
didn't know what any time for that I
didn't realize but it's really cool so
congratulations on four Grammy
nomination I mean that's amazing so how
are you preparing for the big night I
think the dress is the biggest
preparation for a woman on Grammy night
so I've been working with a designer
who's been making me a dress that's just
for me with me in mind so I'm really
excited about seeing that come to life
because I haven't done that before
usually I see it and I pick it I also
got a chance to chat with James Hahn
revival they were awesome they wrote
their
here in Utah in a little cabin England
when evaded to be a studio it is the
irony of all of this is your album is
called Utah we are in Utah and can you
tell me the story of how this album kind
of came about its origins were just in
the fact that we moved from Austin to
Los Angeles start telling that story to
record the album we decided the best
thing to do would be able to turn a log
cabin into a recording studio so we did
that we had this cabin in Utah that we
were familiar with and we thought it'd
be a really cool place to record the
album so we packed up the truck
basically put a whole entire recording
studio into a 20-foot Ryder truck and
drove it to Utah you want to stand next
to him and get your picture with them I
think that woman is wearing she wearing
him over there
Allen
that's it for first date Sundance I got
a lot of really awesome interviews I'll
put a link in the description where you
can check them all out in their entirety
and now we're about to go head out for
day two so you guys can watch that video
tomorrow see you later say bye John I
like you want to drink my coffee Cheers